we here at this term all the time and it
drives me insane well first off
sometimes we hear politicians refer to
millionaires and billionaires as if that
were the same thing
and it's like saying thousand airs and
millionaires it's the same discrepancy
right why why is this term millionaire
so stigmatized these days as if like a
person is evil because they've worked
really hard all of their life to achieve
this certain level of comfort or wealth
or the ability to give to other people
and I think maybe we don't understand
like what you can also do with wealth is
is part of what I mean yeah you can buy
nice things if you want to buy that in
Ryan and I are we're minimalist but
we're not against owning things you know
we're enclosed right now we we drove a
car here you know like we own stuff we
just don't have excess stuff but the
money that we do make we're able to use
that to invest in other people or to
invest in charity as well can you talk
about the stigma behind this millionaire
mindset yeah a lot of people they do
they make some assumptions about
millionaires that they had to cheat to
be able to get their money that they
inherited their money right that's the
way they got there or they had to go to
an Ivy League school or they had some
luck in the way that they got there and
the reality is is that everyday people
are doing it the everyday way where
they're getting themselves out of debt
they're investing they're allowing time
and compound interest to grow their
money they're staying focused right
they're not allowing their wants to get
in the way of their needs or if they do
they do it with cash so there are a lot
of stigmas out there but I really
appreciate you hitting on to me the most
important thing there are a lot of
charities out there that I believe in
there are a lot of things out there
people that I want to help our veterans
people like that single moms I'm the
product of a single parent so my heart
goes out to a lot of those areas but in
order to be able to help I have to have
the ability and this is gonna sound
weird but I want you to hear the heart
behind it broke people can't help other
people and so if there is some kids you
want to help to feed
there are some charities that you
believe in because you know what they
stand for I've been the father of a
special-needs boy my youngest son and
he's had some serious medical issues and
we've met other families that are
walking through tough situations but in
order for him to be able to help people
I have to be in a position to do that
and I'm talking monetarily we also have
to be in a position to be able to help
with our time and our talent those are
other ways that we're able to give and
so what we have to do is make some
decisions we got to take a stand for
some things and then really start to go
down that path
you